>>T,E MINORI
LEPEABE HEZE FOR A  NFHA
REPORTERS.
>> THE PRESIDENT CALLEON ME.
I LD S
>> HOW ARE YOU FEELING NOW, SIR?
>> I'M FINE. DOCR?>> ANY IDEA .
>> DEHYDRATED?
>> GOT TWATH
YOUR.YOU TALKO A  TOD?RE G
K
A SANDBAG, OF
SS THAT
WAT HAPPENED
>> WREA PATH TO FINISHINNEEEGO O
TOET'S GO  JOHN.
IT WAS A PRESSSL
"OUTFRONT" NOW, .
ISED
COVEREDFOR MANY YEARS.A BASH, I
A MOMENT.S FELSTPE
THAT VIDEOWATCH.
HE S
HE'S BNKHA20S .
Y,HI
WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU?
>> W FF ALVE TO
EVWHAN
McCOL D WAS ANTE
EVE CONIOFOUR MONCH IS BASICAL.
AND ABOUOF PO NETO FOR A
N INJURY, LIKE  W
FROM
AND I THINK TH'S WHAT WE
E STARING STRAIGHT AHEAD
REALLY VERY,ALLY VDITCK  H E TH.
THEN THIS EVENING HELA AND
BETTER.
SO THAT'S GOOD N
BU LOOKED
S E
THENATOR
LOOKED ALMOST DEFLATED
AND RY.RYASY TAKE.T HAPPENS
DENNL
81 S HER A INJURY,
LLTHUET
>> YRED McCONNELL FO
YEARS.
WHM YOUR
PREL RLIN ADER NOTG D IN, JUSTSN
HE DID, AS DR. REINER SAID
BACK TO THE  HPTSCHEDULE FOR THS
DAY.
THEY MIGHT EVEN BES
TONIGHWAITING TO SDETHDE
BILL.
I WAS TOLD THAT HE HAS A DINNE
HE'S STIL
S EVENING.
BUT YOU CAN  SEE THE
L BUT THAN LEADERS WHO WERE
NG AROUND HIIO
NTHEFINALLY REALED
BUODO E ISER ANDN WE NEE  A CAMS
DIFFERENCE, AT LEAST TTHE  WHO
E,T REINER WOULD SEE AND, REL
AFTE
THE INCIDENT.TIONED HE VOTED ANO
A DOIDY THAT DOESN'T MEAN  E ON.
BUT, AIN CONTE OF  WHAT  WAS,  S
ABILIT DHI,
NSEQUENCES?
>> WELL, I THINK IT SPEAKS TO YR
HEVE OROUPLE
T
O THE SENATE FOABSIX S.Y IS LE
EVALTED NOW, I THI I
WED MONTHS AER.IFS PP I
THEN THERE MIGE A REEPEAT IT NO.
BUIFHEIME
WHE  STOPPED ISTARING INTO ALMO
THIS WOULD REALLY
>> SO,MEAN
FOR HI
>> WL,N THE SHORT ,
TO GO OU CER, TO LY MAKING A POT
MA JE  SPOKE TO
THE PRESIDENT, AS YOIDNDJOKE.
REALLY BAD HAPPENED NT OF E  JO.
BUT THE FACT THAT HE'SG E TRNGO
IONALLY SA HANS THAT HE HAS NO
CHANGINYTNG
R TERM.Y -E
HE'SL 2026.
T SEVERAL S,
HE ABSOLY EN